we begin unfortunately with a very
disturbing story from Massachusetts it's
a kidnapping case that threatens to get
so much worse after three bodies were
found in a Massachusetts home police
searched the property in Springfield
throughout the night they say that this
is the last known address of Stewart
Weldon police arrested him on Sunday
after a bizarre traffic stop that
started with a broken taillight
well it led to Weldon being charged with
kidnapping torturing and sexually
assaulting his female passenger now she
is still in the hospital with serious
injuries Anna Werner is near the crime
scene in Springfield Massachusetts and a
good morning good morning so this is the
house that investigators have been
searching behind me this green home next
to that you can see a single car garage
and next to that garage you can see a
tent that investigators set up during
their search they're expected to
continue searching this property today
the police report details how the woman
in that car described to police as she
sobbed uncontrollably his alleged acts
of violence it's as you can imagine a
very complicated investigation all hands
are on deck from the Springfield Police
Department less than eight hours after
police announced two bodies were found
at Stewart Weldon's last known address
district attorney Anthony Golani
revealed last night that a third body
had been discovered more information
came in in the last 24 hours that led
investigators to the home neighbors say
police first arrived late Wednesday but
it started out with two two cop cars
I didn't next thing you know the whole
street was filled with detectives the
search continued all day Thursday
focusing on the garage and yard next to
the house investigators put up a tent
Wheldon was arrested Sunday after a car
chase ended in a crash and scuffle with
officers according to the police report
a woman in the car told officers that
Weldon had been holding her captive for
a month adding that he sexually
assaulted her and beat her with a hammer
she was taken to the hospital with
injuries police described as grotesque
and violent including stab wounds to her
abdomen and a possible fractured jaw
before being transported to the hospital
the woman told police thank you guys for
saving my life
I didn't think I was ever going to get
away CBS station WBZ reports the house
being searched belongs to Weldon's
mother but police are not saying who
else lives there neighbors say they've
seen other people in and around the home
they moved in a while back but they're
sort of sort of quiet secluded it's
freaky I feel like I'm I'm watching TV
and it's not real in my neighborhood
it's very unnerving we've not yet been
able to reach Weldon or anyone from the
family he is in jail on $1,000,000 bond
that bond in connection to charges
lodged against him in connection with
the traffic stop on Sunday and that
alleged kidnapping so far that attorney
has not charged Weldon or anyone else in
connection with the three bodies found
here at the home John
Anna thanks don't feel like single then
humanity of people never ceases to amaze
me when you're stories like this you do
wonder what happened to that guy in his
life mm-hmm